un bel giorno tornando a casa da scuola
un bambino con un segno una lettera
nelle mani di sua madre informandola che
era stato proprio il maestro ad avergli
affidato quel foglio di carta nel
leggere ad alta voce quella lettera
la donna si commosse e gli occhi le si
riempirono di lacrime
vostro figlio è un genio disse in questa
scuola è troppo piccola per lui qui non
abbiamo insegnante idonei alla sua
formazione
la preghiamo perciò di istruirlo lei
personalmente passarono molti anni e
all'età di 61 anni la mamma di thomas
morì nel frattempo lui aveva inventato
la lampadina e brevettato altre 1092
invenzioni diventando un uomo ricco e
famoso
un giorno mentre stava rovistando tra le
cose vecchie di famiglia tutt'a un
tratto scorso un foglio di carta
ripiegato nascosto in un angolo del
cassetto di una scrivania lo prese e lo
aprì sul foglio c'era scritto vostro
figlio a lentezza nell'apprendere dovuta
un ritardo mentale
la preghiamo vivamente di non mandarlo
più nella nostra scuola ora anche se
questo aneddoto non viene riportato in
nessuna biografia ufficiale di edison
cosa sappiamo essere sicuramente vero
perché il giudizio di un adulto può
influenzare enormemente la motivazione
lo sviluppo delle capacità di un bambino
di una bambina nel bene o nel male che
raramente la scuola è il luogo dove si
forgiano i geni che edison era un genio
e se vogliamo credere la storia non
possiamo escludere che la genetica nel
suo caso abbia fortemente avvantaggiato
visto che in questo aneddoto e sua madre
la vera eroina non sono pochi i geni che
a scuola stentavano addirittura erano
considerati portatori di un lieve
ritardo è risaputo per esempio che anche
einstein nei primi anni della sua vita
mostra su un ritardo nell'apprendimento
quando riflettiamo sui personaggi che
con le loro opere le loro scoperte le
loro azioni hanno cambiato il corso
della storia il nostro primo pensiero va
alle loro qualità straordinarie cioè
fuori dalla norma
e sorge una domanda geni si nasce o si
diventa essere un genio determinato dal
nostro dna o ci sono in gioco altri
fattori questi dilemmi hanno
accompagnato la vita professionale di
molti scienziati ricercatori e in
particolare hanno guidato le azioni del
dottor thomas harvey che lavorava come
patologo presso l'ospedale di princeton
nel
55 l'anno della morte di einstein il
fatto scelse harvey per svolgere
l'autopsia sul corpo dello scienziato e
lui senza il consenso della famiglia
prese l'iniziativa di asportarne
conservarne in vasetti di formaldeide il
cervello da lì in poi spese la vita
nello studio minuzioso ti ogni suo cm
alla ricerca di una spiegazione organica
della genialità il presupposto di questa
dedizione era ovviamente che il segreto
del genio risiedesse nella sua
conformazione cerebrale
harvey desiderava ardentemente scoprire
quale fosse la caratteristica anatomica
che aveva reso albert einstein in vita
ancora oggi l'icona dell'intelligenza
nel mondo
purtroppo per lui e contro ogni
aspettativa quel cervello d'eccezione
risulta normalissimo per dirla tutta
pesava il 10 per cento in meno rispetto
alla media
gli studi che si sono susseguiti non
trovarono ciò che rendeva ansa in quello
che era
passarono quasi tre decenni prima che
avvenisse il miracolo erano gli inizi
degli anni 80 quando mary ann diamond
neuro anatomy st dell'università della
california a berkeley annunciò una
scoperta sorprendente destinata a
rivoluzionare il mondo
dell'apprendimento
ma soprattutto le idee riguardanti la
genialità
la maggior parte della gente con una
convinta che geni si nasca ma la
dottoressa diamond e dico tutta la sua
ricerca a creare geni in laboratorio in
un famoso esperimento la ricercatrice e
posa confronto due gruppi di topi fece
crescere il primo in un ambiente
stimolante dotato di scivoli altalene
ruote e ogni tipo di gioco possibile
l'altro gruppo lo sistemo invece in un
ambiente standard composto da semplici
gabbie vuote
il risultato dell'esperimento fu che i
topi che vivevano nell'ambiente
stimolante raggiunsero l'eccezionalità
di tre anni in proporzione circa 90 anni
per un essere umano e nel loro cervello
era aumentata la componente trofica la
glia che favorisce lo scambio di
informazioni tra cellule nervose al
contrario i topi che vivevano nelle
gabbie normali rimasero inattivi avevano
un tasso di mortalità più alto e
presentavano molti meno collegamenti
all'interno della
sarà bello la diamond vuole scoprire se
ciò potesse essere valido anche per gli
esseri umani
perciò di chiese e ottenne sezioni del
cervello di einstein da esaminare come
si aspettava riscontrò un gran numero di
cellule gliali nel lobo parietale
sinistro una specie di stazione di
scambio neuro neurologico che la
scienziata stessa descrisse come un area
di associazione per le altre aree di
associazioni del cervello
la dottoressa aveva previsto tale
risultato data l'altissima
concentrazione di cellule gliali che
aveva riscontrato nel gruppo di topi più
stimolati dall'ambiente negli ultimi 30
anni si è giunti alla conclusione che le
capacità che definiamo talento o
addirittura genio non sono un dono della
natura con cui veniamo al mondo bensì la
combinazione di abilità istruzione e
formazione di alto livello è una
montagna di lavoro e di esercizio più
cresciamo ci allontaniamo dall'infanzia
meno importante sarà l'impatto della
genetica sul nostro consente
intellettivo e sono tre risultati quindi
non importa da dove vieni
chi siano i tuoi genitori e che lavoro
facciano facessero e il modo in cui
spegne la tua vita il tuo atteggiamento
i comportamenti che adotti le abitudine
che crei ciò su cui ti focalizzi rendono
la tua mente ciò che è la domanda che
bisogna porsi riguarda quali siano gli
scivoli altalene le ruote ai giochi che
permettono all'essere umano di accendere
l'intelligenza e migliorare quindi
l'apprendimento e alla ricerca e
sviluppo di questa cassetta degli
attrezzi che in molti si sono dedicati
negli ultimi vent'anni ed è la
diffusione di questi strumenti che potrà
aiutare il nostro mondo ad affrontare il
cataclisma che sta trasformando l'era
dell'intelligenza dell'informazione
gratuita abbondante nell'era della
disinformazione e dell analfabetismo
funzionale
in italia abbiamo il minor numero di
laureati è più fuori corsi rispetto agli
altri paesi europei
le conseguenze economiche e sociali sono
devastanti a partire dai dati sulla
criminalità ma se anche non si arriva a
tanto l'incapacità presa fa morire sogni
l'italia sta diventando un paese da cui
sembra che se hai il cervello è meglio
fuggire
ecco perché farà innamorare le persone
dello studio è una cosa così importante
e poi come se non bastasse tutte queste
difficoltà se non sono risolte quando
siamo sui banchi di scuola
rimangono come dei buchi nei quali si
finisce poi per inciampare spesso anche
nel mondo del lavoro
ti manca la motivazione nella memoria
chi manca la concentrazione ai l'ansia
di non riuscire a imparare non ti senti
portato per certe materie o magari per
le lingue studiare un'attività faticosa
che ti causa stress e non ti regala
soddisfazioni
ognuno di questi problemi probabilmente
può essere superato sforzandosi
impegnandosi di più ma non è questa la
strada che suggeriscono gli esperti
perché in realtà ognuno di questi
problemi ha una radice comune nessuno ci
ha insegnato ad apprendere la scuola
come dice il professor piero formica è
focalizzata sull'insegnamento non
sull'apprendimento a scuola ci viene
detto cosa studiare ma nessuno ci
insegna come tantissime persone che
magari non hanno vicino qualcuno come la
fama di edison
crescono quindi pensando di non essere
portate per lo studio o per certe
materia in particolare pensano magari
addirittura di non essere intelligenti
abbastanza e rinunciano all'idea di
realizzare i loro sogni quando in realtà
quello che manca loro è semplicemente il
metodo giusto ma non è questo metodo
giusto allora partiamo dalle basi
io ho identificato tre elementi
fondamentali per sviluppare intelligenza
e genialità nel momento in cui ti dici
la mia mente non è più quella di un
tempo oppure oggi non riesco a
ricordarmi niente sono troppo lento sono
troppo scarso è troppo difficile in
reatà stai portando il tuo cervello a
ridurre l'energia di cui può nutrirsi il
primo pilastro è l'atteggiamento insieme
di convinzioni e credenze che ai miei
confronti di te stesso della tua
intelligenza della tua personalità ma in
particolare a prescindere da quanto noi
pensiamo di valere quello che conta è
quanto siamo convinti di poter
migliorare queste caratteristiche
uno degli aspetti singolari del cervello
umano e che ci può portare solo dove la
nostra mente pensa di poter arrivare
purtroppo la maggior parte delle persone
utilizza frasi come non riesco più a
fare
che facevo da giovane non sono portato
non sarò mai capace di fare ciò che fa
lui invece di tentare in un altro modo e
poi usa queste espressioni convincendo
se ne per avere un alibi e smettere di
impegnarsi veramente in realtà siamo
progettati per apprendere per migliorare
e crescere niente più falso del pensare
di non poterlo fare o di non esserci
portati sono solo scuse immagina che il
cervello sia un violino stradivari che
lo impugna un principiante o un virtuoso
come paganini il violino e fisicamente
lo stesso ma la musica che produrrà sarà
molto diversa
il principiante utilizza meno dell'un
per cento del potenziale dello strumento
invece il virtuoso lo spinge oltre i
suoi limiti
bene una volta fatto tuo l'atteggiamento
mentale giusto impara e utilizza le
migliori tecniche per potenziare le
connessioni cerebrali migliorare il
quoziente intellettivo e la capacità di
individuare soluzioni risolvere problemi
a realizzare ciò che desideri passa
attraverso il corretto allenamento della
mente il secondo pilastro quindi a
sostegno dello sviluppo del nostro
potenziale di apprendimento sono quindi
una serie di tecniche ed esercizi che
stanno alla comprensione
all'intelligenza come il diritto al
rovescio stanno al tennis
si tratta di veri e propri fondamentali
dell'apprendimento
effettivamente è proprio così che sono
stati definiti dall'ingegner massimo
razzano primo ricercatore del consiglio
nazionale delle ricerche di torino il
cnr uno degli enti più prestigiosi e
autorevoli al mondo per la ricerca lo
studio aveva mosso i primi passi dall
osservazione da parte di adattano
durante i primi anni di lavoro al cnr
delle obiettive difficoltà nate esisti e
dottorandi esprimere a raccontare con
chiarezza
l'esito del loro lavoro di tesi con
l'approccio tipico del ricercatore venne
posto sotto la lente di ingrandimento un
problema così diffuso da sembrare realtà
la normalità
l'incapacità di esprimere con chiarezza
concetti complessi era ed è infatti
diffusissima capire da cosa dipende se
questa difficoltà è stato l'obiettivo
principale della ricerca il secondo
ovviamente è stato quello poi di trovare
una soluzione valida possibilmente per
chiunque
il primo frutto di questo lavoro è
arrivato nel momento in cui è stato
possibile dimostrare che le difficoltà
di espressione dipendono dalla mancanza
di comprensione chiarezza degli elementi
di base del pensiero del discorso le
parole ei termini specifici della
materia trattata aumentando poi
l'ingrandimento della lente si è visto
successivamente che in realtà la
difficoltà a esprimere i concetti non si
limitava a quelli complessi ma comprende
ma anche quelli più semplici noti e di
uso comune che non abbiamo studiato a
scuola ma abbiamo appreso con
l'esperienza in modo spontaneo naturale
attraverso l'osservazione l'ascolto e la
pratica ripetuta per risolvere il
problema sono stati sperimentate
tecniche e approcci diversi e sono stati
infine identificati dai ricercatori
degli strumenti efficacissimi per
migliorare la comprensione delle
capacità espressive non solo dei
laureandi ma di un pubblico molto
eterogeneo di apprendisti dal ragazzo
delle medie fino all'ingegneria iscritto
all'albo
la nostra collaborazione con i
ricercatori del cnr nel divulgare questi
metodi a un numero sempre maggiore di
persone si collega a un obiettivo molto
ambizioso quello di creare un anello di
congiunzione tra la ricerca troppo
spesso priva di applicazioni pratiche o
appannaggio di pochi addetti ai lavori e
poi la divulgazione troppo spesso
farcita in marketing di imprecisioni più
che di semplificazioni appena ne avrai
l'occasione fai questo esperimento su un
foglio bianco scrivi la definizione di
un numero non utilizzare il computer
solo carta e penna in modo da lasciare
traccia anche di eventuali correzioni
che poi vorrei annotare per raggiungere
un risultato che ridarà e soddisfacente
ovviamente non cercare la definizione
sul dizionario che altrimenti
l'esercizio risulterà inutile dati un
paio di minuti la prima di googlare
numero e quindi proci sul serio si
tratta all'apparenza di un esercizio
elementare perché numero è un concetto
noto un concetto comunissimo di cui
sicuramente conosce il significato
eppure avresti mai immaginato che fosse
così complesso riuscire a formulare
quella selezione precisa e ordinata di
parole per descrivere in modo efficace
comprensibile chiaro sintetico ed
esaustivo il concetto ti stupiresti in
realtà di quanta difficoltà potreste
riscontrare nel trovare le parole
corrette per definire oggetti che la
quotidianità ti presenta continuamente
come tavolo o volante
l'ingegner adattano utilizzare una
metafora molto suggestiva per descrivere
questa procedura di ricerca e selezione
delle parole più adatte che poi devono
essere composte nell'ordine più logico e
funzionale per restituire verbalmente un
concetto appreso con l'esperienza lo
chiama il precipitato di parole
il riferimento è a quel fenomeno in cui
in una soluzione chimica a causa di una
reazione che aumenta la concentrazione
del saluto oppure di una variazione
delle condizioni fisiche della soluzione
viene superato il limite di solubilità e
quindi il solito precipita verso il
fondo come solido separandosi da
assorbente immagina di vedere le miriadi
di parole che conosci fluttuare in
distinte nella tua mente e poi di
attivare un processo in grado di
produrre come risultato una frase
un'espressione che descrive in modo
accurato quel concetto depositandosi sul
foglio sotto forma di scrittura perché
tutto tranne che semplice produrre a
questo risultato
potremmo dire proseguendo nella metafora
che probabilmente non hai chiara la
reazione chimica da innescare o quali
condizioni fisiche devono essere
modificate e come per produrre il
precipitato le difficoltà che incontri
sono causate dal fatto che
l'apprendimento maturato con
l'esperienza sfrutta canali e competenze
diverse rispetto all apprendimento
attraverso l'uso della parola ed è tanto
complesso trasporre in una frase ciò che
si è imparato con il proprio vissuto
quanto portare nella consapevolezza
dell'esperienza ciò che si legge da un
testo o che si impara dall'ascolto
l'effetto straordinario della pratica di
questo fondamentale è un risveglio
dell'intelligenza una maggiore
sensazione di controllo è un
miglioramento nella comprensione dei
testi e delle capacità espressive i
fondamentali dell'apprendimento sono
molteplici e il tempo a disposizione
troppo breve per presentarli tutti
quindi passiamo direttamente al terzo e
ultimo pilastro il terzo pilastro per
rifondare il nostro amore per
l'apprendimento e per accendere
l'intelligenza e costruire un metodo di
studio personalizzato tutti abbiamo
sentito dire che il metodo è qualcosa di
soggettivo ma questo non significa
necessariamente
che si debba o si possa costruirlo da
soli per quanto mi riguarda questo è
proprio l'aspetto a cui ho dedicato in
assoluto più tempo nella mia ricerca
partendo dall insegnamento di tecniche
di memoria lettura veloce ma per mentali
mi sono reso conto negli anni che molti
ottenevano bellissimi risultati ma
alcuni a distanza di poco tempo passato
magari l'entusiasmo iniziale la carica
motivazionale che nasce dal rendersi
conto di riuscire a fare delle cose che
ti sembravano impossibili fino a poco
prima di conoscerle tecniche
abbandonavano per strada
la maggior parte degli strumenti mi sono
reso conto che aver preteso che queste
persone utilizzassero con profitto un
set di tecniche era stato perdente
quanto l'approccio di un oculista cui ci
rivolgiamo che invece di diagnosticare
con una visita accurata il nostro
problema si togliesse gli occhiali e ci
riportasse per indossarli aspettandosi
poi che funzionino anche per noi
assurdo ciò che inconsapevolmente
cercavano in corsisti del corso di
tecniche era un metodo di studio quello
che trovavano era una cassetta degli
attrezzi fondamentale sì ma non
progettata sulle loro esigenze sulle
loro caratteristiche
ho sperimentato perciò negli ultimi anni
molteplici sistemi per identificare con
chiarezza il personale stile di
apprendimento e alla fine ho trovato in
una batteria di questionari sviluppata
dal team del professor cesare cornoldi
dell'università di padova uno degli
strumenti più funzionali per riconoscere
come il nostro cervello piace imparare
sulla base di questa consapevolezza si
può cominciare a costruire finalmente un
metodo efficace personalizzato basato
sui propri punti di forza sulle qualità
vincenti accompagnati da esperti
appositamente formati e piu facile e
sicuro questo strumento permette anche
di identificare in certe situazioni dei
blocchi o grandi difficoltà chi è il
mostro da abbattere
quando magari sono così tanti da non
capire nemmeno da dove cominciare spesso
buttato giù il capostipite gli altri
scappano e non si e se non si ritirano
subito sono più arrendevoli per quando
vi si affronta questi riferimenti non
fanno altro che costituire un booster
per il nostro atteggiamento innescando
quel circolo virtuoso che ci permette di
sviluppare ancora intelligenza e
genialità di tutto questo abbiamo
bisogno ancor più che per imparare una
lingua o per laurearci in corso per
districarci fra l'effetto news per fare
ordine nella
quanti tudine di informazione che ci
sommerge ogni giorno per leggere e
capire meglio non solo i libri ma
soprattutto cosa ci accada e capire la
vita
l'attività precipua dell'essere umano è
l'apprendimento la conoscenza dentro di
noi è racchiusa la stessa potenzialità
che ha dato vita alla teoria della
relatività ai viaggi sulla luna alle
sinfonie di vivaldi al tiramisù alla
cappella sistina
ora questo è proprio un particolare
della cappella sistina una delle opere
più famose di vinca langeli se
osserviamo bene possiamo notare che la
cerchia di angeli intorno alla figura di
dio sembra proprio ricordare la forma di
un cervello umano con questa immagine
come ancora di quanto importante sia il
percorso di conoscenza di ogni essere
umano
mi auguro di lasciarti con la
consapevolezza che sarà vera la risposta
che darei tu alla domanda iniziale se
geni si nasce o si diventa
perché sta solo a te a sceglierlo